uh yeah so
i'm glad i'm a second year phd student
at
imperial college london in the
computational
photochemistry group and i've been
trying to convince
my peer group and various other people
to to join
the python world i'm going to talk a bit
about
what that means i mean i guess we've
heard a lot about how to use big data
and all the processes you can use i
guess i'm going to talk more about how
you can
set sources of closed data free i mean
i'm working in a world where they're
really
shut down i'm trying to make them more
more open to the kind of techniques we
we've heard today
so yeah i guess i'm going to talk a bit
about what chemistry
quantum chemistry is what tools we use
why i think there are problems with our
current tool sets
what python can bring to the table and
building an ipython notebook that you
can use for quantum chemical research
and then some conclusions uh so what's
quantum chemistry well we've known
since 1929 the fundamental laws of
nature sufficient to compute
any of the properties of matter that we
might want to compute
so dirac famously made this this
statement towards that effect
um so what are the equations you're
trying to solve well
they're it's called the schrodinger
equation and
it's not appearing there good good but
if it if mathematics was working it
would appear here
so in the classical in classical physics
we can compute
say how atom uh how planets move around
themselves in the sun
by solving newton's laws and we can do
the equivalent in quantum mechanics to
specify all the different states of an
electron moving around some set of
nuclei
by by solving the schrodinger equation
and we can do that
analytically in the case of a small
system like hydrogen
and that can give us say these kinds of
plots which
tell us where the electron can be
distributed around
a single atom and we can do that with
just pen and paper
the problem comes if we want to go
beyond a single atom
very quickly we we hit problems uh
because we can't solve the uh
the equations and the end of dirac's uh
sentence is then
after he says we can solve everything
already he goes it therefore becomes
desirable that approximate practical
methods of applying quantum mechanics
be developed which can lead to an
explanation of the main features of
complex atomic systems
and since then the majority of research
in this field has been
towards constructing these approximate
methods so we can compute
answers accurately enough to well to be
chemically or physically useful
so we've done quite a lot since 1929 so
back then you could compute i mean a
diatomic molecule if you
push yourself whereas nowadays you can
do quite a lot i mean this is a bit of a
cheat
but it looked pretty cool so i decided
to put it up anyway so this is a mixture
of a classical
and a quantum simulation and it spans uh
200 proteins which is 10 million atoms
so it's not entirely quantum but they
they are coupling the the chromophores
which the light sensitive parts of these
proteins together
and treating them uh quantum
mechanically which is an astonishing
change considering well compared to what
we could do
in the 1930s i mean it's like a being
able to simulate a football and then
going to being able to simulate
the o2 arena so
so yeah we've developed many different
methods to do this because
it's pretty uh old fields and they break
down into different ways of turning the
equations into different equations that
are
simpler and then different numerical
approximations
of those simplified equations and
combined together there are many many
different ways to do this and there's a
lot of different choice
uh and that's kind of built into a lot
of different programs i mean
there are new programs being built all
the time but some of the biggest that
are used
today are stuff that began life in the
60s and this is a tiny subsection of
them they just
happen to be the ones compatible with a
library i'm going to use later
um and yeah in academia at least in the
field that i work in
it's the large ones 1950s that dominate
primarily because the number of
manuals of development that's gone into
them mean they have more methods and
they can do more properties than other
other codes and that's great but the
problem is that they're designed
with a mindset from another era i mean
that
they're completely out of touch in
certain respects they're completely out
of touch with with our modern
uh tool set i mean in fact if you look
at the source code as i have
you still see it's it's written in
fortran 77
as if it's being computed on punch cards
and it's littered with
go-to statements and other things that
make modern computer scientists cry
so yeah that's the code itself and when
it comes to running these things
uh well what people do is that they
write text files out
you know that and they can be simple i
mean this case is just uh
two two atoms a dimer and it's choosing
uh it's specifying the coordinates and
it's specifying the method and how much
computer power to use
and that's not so bad but it can also be
evil i mean you can have to specify
horrible machine codes that you have to
look up deliberately
i mean you have to consult people for
you need to specify
numerous parameters for thousands or in
some cases hundreds of thousands of
atoms
i mean that's what's going on there then
they specify the connectivity between
all the atoms
parameters for force fields you're going
to use if you had to do this by hand
it would be almost impractical and
practically impossible
and fortunately there are some tools to
do this but
and without them you wouldn't be able to
do some of these calculations but
they're really
imperfect tools they they're incomplete
they don't cover all the functionality
you could use the program for
they're closed source or the most
effective and commonly used ones are
closed source they're not extendable
they're not scriptable
and they cost a lot of money so we
should be doing better than this in in
2014
uh and yeah though the the programs
themselves
i mean in the case of the the main ones
they have decent documentation
certainly gaussian which is the one i'm
going to talk about there are lots of
clever uh machine codes you can put in
to make your calculations more effective
but there's
the documentation doesn't exist i mean
the only way to find out how to do this
stuff is to go an apprentice with
some one one of the old gurus who knows
how and then you know you try and
do tasks for them in the hope that they
give you the secret knowledge to do the
calculations you want to do
so yeah well this is that's great i mean
this is a schematic and it's details
aren't important but i was handed this
when i started my phd and it was like
how to do one calculation on a protein
and it's all like use this program to
prepare this part and then
take the input file and edit it by hand
and then copy this bit from this other
like six different programs and hand it
it's crazy
um so once you have your you've created
your input file you submit it to
a cluster and away it goes and what you
get back
is in fact another text document which
is
as difficult to to cope with as the
input file in that
it's basically the debug output of the
code whilst it's running it prints out
all manner of different details um i
mean this is a small section of it it
doesn't look too bad but
it is completely non-standard so so for
instance if you want to calculate the
energy of a set of molecules
and you use one method you might think
if you use another method it's going to
be in the same place and be the same
line no no it's not it's going to be
somewhere completely different
it's going to look completely different
your you know the string you're going to
grab for one is not going to work for
the other
if you're lucky you won't be able to
grab you know if you're lucky you can
grab it if you're not you're gonna have
to write a custom
aux script to pull it out um
so yeah there is a bit of machine
readable data in these things at the end
but
it's incomplete and there is also
another machine readable output um
which is its own close this is its own
separate format but it's reasonable um
you can turn it into you can read it
pretty easily but it doesn't actually
include all the information you can't
you can't get away from these hideous
log files um so so yeah that's what
people do they they build these things
in a complicated tool chain that
sometimes you can visualize a small
amount of the data
with the gui but generally people will
either open the things and copy and
paste into excel the calculation data
they want or if they're sophisticated
they'll write custom bash or shell
scripts for their individual use cases
uh so yeah this is kind of the workflow
that they
they adopt they build their molecule
they build their input file they build
the job script to submit it to the
cluster they submit to the cluster they
look to check if
everything's okay if it's not they
change something if
it looks okay then they they apply their
custom script to pull out the data
which they then you know use to i don't
know some plotting like really like xm
grace or new plus
to plot um and
they don't have any real wealth there's
no standard way to have a record of what
you do these people have their own ways
of keeping notes
but on numerous occasions people will
come back to previous calculations that
worked and
not keep track of this process that this
iterative process they've used
to figure out how to make a calculation
work is well
if they if they're good they'd document
as they go but there's no standard ways
to do this
and so and that's reflected in in the
literature so when people report the
calculations they normally report
uh you know the output of this iterative
process so they make the calculation
work and they give you an overview of
how
the kind of commands they've done but if
you want to come and reproduce it
yourself
there can be lots of hidden gotchas that
they don't include little machine code
changes they
are little iop codes they put in or
something that meant their initial
calculation failed and they did all this
extra stuff but
you don't know about that because they
haven't included it in the literature
and
they haven't included sometimes you get
input files more likely you get a load
of
strings or you get a load of text files
with some some numbers representing
structures
um so yeah i have a lot of problems with
this i think it's a really inefficient
process
i think the exchange of information
through the literature is really low
bandwidth
so there's no reason we can't get all of
their this process they've used we can't
have all the information that they
they've gone through um and i think it
really limits the usage of the kind of
calculations we can do because
you make people go through all this pain
to do a single calculation so there
could be all kinds of interesting ways
to combine
quantum chemistry with other fields
that's massively limited because
we just can't plug stuff together very
easily
so how can python help well we can we
can sort this out with a glue language
like python we can replace these
medieval practices of writing elaborate
text files and
and reading aneurysm inducing output
files
and we can run all of our calculations
if we wrap it in this way
inside a notebook and that way we've got
a kind of curated store of our
our research process uh which we can we
can share with other people
um so so that's what what uh
a lot of other people have been involved
with and and i have two so
i'm going to talk about some of the the
libraries i'm going to use and
mostly this this ase which is this
atomic simulation environment which
these guys in denmark have set up to try
and
to do this and to combine a lot of these
ab initio codes in a way that can be
talked to in a systematic manner and cc
lib which is a passing library so you
combine these two
you can get most of what we want which
is a quantum chemical api
um so the atomic simulation environment
is written by this was constructed by
this group in denmark and
is slowly being used more you can define
atoms objects in a reasonably sensible
way
and yeah so here i'm defining a nitrogen
dimer
just specifying the positions and the
molecule itself
and you can build a crystal from a from
a lattice so
i'm building a copper fcc
cluster telling it how big it is and
putting a slab of vacuum
on on the top uh and or you can read
from structures you've created or you've
downloaded from from a structured
database
um so then once you have your your
object you can attach one of the
calculators that's been
uh implemented and you can use that to
do calculations so behind the scenes
it's sending off stuff to whichever
calculator
you've asked a really basic one is this
this emt which is from their tutorial
and it's only implemented energy
enforcers but the more sophisticated
ones implement
many more methods and then you can use
it to compute energies or
to do other more interesting things i
mean the philosophy tends to be to write
small scripts that make use of the
calculators to
uh compute specific properties and then
asc's own machinery
is used for like optimization so in this
example that they're going to compute
a slab of copper and calculate the
energy and then
then a nitrogen molecule and calculate
the energy
and then they stack the nitrogen on top
of the copper
they freeze the copper they run an
optimization to lower the energy which
kind of relaxes the copper
of the nitrogen onto the copper surface
and then they they take the difference
in energy so they get the absorption
energy
um and they don't have to do it by hand
and they have this this nice this nice
way of doing it
um and the cc lib is a library for
passing it's been implemented uh
since 2008 and they have a lot of the
major codes
uh that you can just yeah you can just
slot slot into their passer and they
handle lots of the all the horrible use
cases that that uh
all the horrible formats that that that
the the legacy codes give you and
they're constantly of course
having their passes broken because the
the these people don't really cooperate
they just change it randomly but there's
enough of a community
going that they fix it so usually your
passes are working
and then you you have your your format
in a nice
an array or some other um machine
readable formats
um and finally there's another toolkit
uh which has been developed in in
belgium and their focus is on
manipulation
of uh an analysis of molecular data
rather than construction of files
there's a lot of overlap between a lots
of these at the library so there's no
not yet a unifying uh infrastructure but
they cover a lot of functionality and
if you plug them together with bits of
glue you can do a lot
um so in this case they're defining the
molecular graph so
how you're going to bond your atoms
together given that you only have
positions of atoms
they also have some the parsers for the
machine readable components of
the specialized machine report file so
plugging this all together kind of gives
me
an overall api and then of course the
ipython notebook
i want to run it inside that i guess you
guys all know what that is
um and then there are visualization
libraries
jmol is a nice visualization library
that's written in in javascript
so you could you can have your your
molecule sitting nicely in your
your notebook you can visualize uh
electrons or the
molecular structures themselves or
vibrations um which is great
and it's cool spins amazing um
so yeah and then
so the glue code i i was trying to add
to this is just a way of
operating over ssh because i want to run
calculations from inside
a notebook somewhere away from the
cluster and i wanted to handle it itself
when so when i tell it to go calculate
some property
it's going to go away it's going to
submit stuff to the cluster and it's
going to give me back the answer
so in order to do that that's a slightly
change in the in the usage
of some of these libraries i picked up
parameco
and pbs library and i basically stuck
them together into some glue with some
some javascript
so yeah so in the combination we can
make this quantum chemical api and by
using the notebook we can kind of create
this kind of curated research
output that could be shared really
effectively with other people
um so what does it look like well it
kind of looks like this
we import the the whole thing and we can
we can run stuff dynamically
from where we are so i'm reading in a
molecule
of graphene in this case i specify
the methods i want to use and the amount
of
cluster space i want to use and then
then i submit the calculation
and i do it with two different variants
because i'm interested in what's
happening when i get back
is a kind of a table that looks like
this telling me
what succeeds and what's not and in the
actual thing i can
because i'm in this html slides i can't
click on these things
but if i want to look further into the
the actual output i can link it to any
number of different programs i can link
it to just an editor or
or some other program to analyze the
individual data
itself but most importantly i have all
of it in a in a format that i can access
i can loop over i can
i can send it to something else i can
collect a million of these calculations
and then send them
to one of the libraries or one of the
techniques we've we've
seen today um so yeah it's just a a
dipole moment so a charge
distribution um so yeah you can use it
to do
in in one step what what one of the
previous uh
that previous optimization step with asc
took the script because we
have wrapped the whole of the the
calculator we're not using
any of the internal machinery we can do
it in just just one line
um and most importantly you can do like
really complicated stuff or stuff that
would be a real hassle to do
if you were writing stuff out so what i
want to do here is i want to
take a reaction between two molecules i
want to find how it's going to react and
then take
sequences snapshots along this and for
each snapshot
compute some vibrational property and
then plot that now if i had to do that
by hand
well i could write out the first two
calculations by hand but then i have to
wait for the output
to i'd have to read through the the
output and or write a custom script for
this particular use case
pull it all out individually put it in
different files run those individually
it's a pain whereas in this format it's
really simple i can just
i just define them one sequentially and
then
i can loop over their subsequent uh
snapshots
and run the new calculations and into in
eight lines or so i have done everything
i want to do
and then yeah then i could plot it
because i have i have it um this is one
of the vibrations along these snapshots
so it just makes life uh much easier
um you can also do things like mix
quantum mechanics and classical
mechanics and
this can also be a pain you can't really
do this without one of the guise because
it has to work out a lot of things on
the fly like how when you tell it to cut
stuff up
and to take a molecule and to use the
center and treat that
quantumly the rest classically a lot has
to be worked out to pass
and it's like how they to connect
together to pass
on to the underlying calculators and we
can do that again in gaussian and make
it
in in python and make it nice and easy
to do
um yeah so and it generates files
for us that then then passes on um
yeah and rather than having to read
through 24 to 21 000 lines about but we
can just
use our python so at the moment
i can run a reasonable subset of
gaussian i'm working on that
and extract almost all of the data from
it view and manipulate
the structures and we have an api
what i'd like to do is to extend the the
construction
calculations to the full proteins which
is that long
set of the thing i got handed that takes
three days i want it to take three
minutes and
hopefully it will and i also want to to
extend the notebook so that we can use
it as a as this curated
uh research uh framework so so i want to
have
uh what amounts to a dashboard for the
notebook with nodes connected together
where each node represents some some
part of your research so calculations uh
that lead on one from another and then
go through to analysis and then some
kind of
uh final uh output that you want to
report but also the dead ends the stuff
that didn't work
so then if someone has this that they
can see what you've done they can they
can really
there's no problem to reproducing your
calculations if they can really see what
you've done and why you've done it
and they get a lot of the information
they get a lot of information out of
this and i think it would speed up
a lot of um yeah a lot of the research
we're doing
so i'm hoping to write my thesis as a
kind of set of these linked
uh project trees one for each chapter
and yeah that's that's what i'm trying
to do so
many thanks to my supervisor and the
epos rc and the people who've already
built most of this stuff
and i'll take any questions if there are
any